hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
I said can we do a cold oak with a cold
open with no theme music where we draw a
cold open okay so I feel like on
especially important dear Hank and John
episodes when we have especially
important news we should start with the
cold open instead of starting with the
music I didn't realize there wasn't
specially important news oh yeah
hello this is Hank and John Green no no
we are already in the cold open Hank
okay what is the especially important
news
what do you why are you looking at your
phone I'm at VidCon I'm organizing
things the especially important news
well there's two pieces of especially
important news that we have to get to
before I think we start the podcast okay
the first is that in the last episode of
dear Hank and John I slightly undercut
my argument that I am acquainted with
the Pope by Miss naming the Pope yes you
did call him Benedict in fact his name
is Francis I want to apologize to my
friend the Pope for using the wrong name
the second and most important news Hank
is that in our last episode you and I
made a bet about whether humans will get
to Mars by 2027 okay and I said that I
was gonna start a Twitter yeah Leon mas
yeah for Earth Leon must for Earth
number four Leon must number for Earth
and that Twitter which you said I was
not serious about and I didn't say he
was series about I said you weren't
gonna follow through and I do not call
this a week later following through
first off
Leon must for earth number for Leon must
at Leon must number for Earth has 1265
Twitter followers Hank do you know how
many accounts he follows one one you
know what that account is at NASA Earth
NASA Earth NASA's greatest work NASA
does do a lot of important earth science
oh I would argue it's actually the only
important science they do
I am so committed Hank why is this
before the intro because hey well on big
big days we need to do cold opens Leon
must for Earth is the biggest
development in vlog
brothers since arguably 2007 all right
should we enter the podcast now all
right let's launch the theme music hello
and welcome to dear Hank and John now
first thing that Dear John and Hank it's
a comedy podcast where me and my brother
John give you dubious advice answer your
questions bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon and we
are together right now in Anaheim
California yeah we're here for VidCon
VidCon VidCon it's happening okay - I
have one of those lovely Hank and John
are in the same place podcasts which are
some of my favorites are we recording we
are okay I was looking at the thing to
make sure Leone mas asks question time
what's your favorite thing about Earth
for me it's how much better it is at
supporting life than Mars how are you
doing John I'm doing great
Hank I've never been so committed to a
project as I am committed to the Leone
must for Earth project you know Leon
Moss he's even invented a hashtag yeah
to support his cause hashtag yes Earth
yeah
hashtag earth life that's another one
that he really likes to use and then of
course a hashtag not till 2028
I am gonna win this bet there will be no
humans on Mars - until 2028 at the very
earliest thanks to the hard work on
Twitter of noted earth activist Leon
Maas and all of the 1,200 something
people following Leon I mean it's gonna
be more by the time this is uploaded in
fact Hank just while we've been having
this conversation Leon must for Earth
got a new follower oh I'm very excited
for him don't worry I'm gonna name I'm
gonna name them Keira Carey I just want
to say thank you thanks for standing for
Earth hashtag hashtag yes Earth
hashtag no earth yes Mars no both both
we've got a great planet I can't wait to
win this bet we still haven't decided
what the terms are going to be a lot
lots of people had great suggestions but
keep sending in your suggestions for
what you would like the terms of my bet
with Hank to be over whether or not a
AFC Wimbledon will make it to the
Premier League by 2027 and B whether or
not humans will make it to Mars by 2027
so we've got a suggestion from Jess who
says if there are no humans on Mars in
ten years the podcast shall be renamed
Dear John and Hank oh that's a fantastic
idea that is a fantastic idea that's it
we found it so we are just 11 short
years away from my dream coming true and
this podcast being called Dear John and
a nature of the universe shall change I
mean that's the best possible victory
all right John do you want to do some
questions or do you have a short poem
for us you know let's just uh let's just
go you know if I could just read one
short poem Hank okay well that's usually
how you do it do you know do you mind
yeah don't do - I won't do - I'm just
gonna do one short poem for the day it's
a prose poem by Leon muscle it's by Leon
bus right it's a poem by Leon Maas it's
on his Twitter at Leon must number for
Earth people often ask me Leon Maas
should we send humans to Mars and I
always tell them yes in 2028 and not a
day sooner you're welcome for this short
poem I've already had more fun on this
podcast than I usually have all week
long hey let's answer some questions
from our listeners all right this one is
from the tunnel and Noah and Israel
Matano asks my wife keeps asking me to
ask you guys the question in the subject
line which is why does the urge to pee
increase as I get closer to my apartment
and even more so right at the door is
there a reason for the same because
there's a different reason I have it to
where I like the closer you get to the
bathroom a more you have to pee in fact
the most recent time I peed my pants
was precisely because of this phenomenon
yeah
you've gotten to the place I didn't pee
my pants but I did pee in a non ideal
location because I'd realized that I was
either going to pee right in my pants or
I was going to pee in the non ideal
location while not getting pee in my
pants yeah it was when I was on the set
of the Paper Towns movie and we had
apartments all of us had apartments in
the same apartment building and I had
the really intense urge to pee as I got
closer to the apartment it got more
intense it got more intense it got more
intense and then I realized that didn't
have a key so you just peed on your
apartment
no so I just ran outside and I peed I
can't tell the story no it's too late
I'm backing off on the way I'm walking
away from this story the short answer is
that we don't know no I do know oh hey
doesn't it along your urethra Oh have a
series of 86 stinkers well and I'm
making this up you had me sold I was
like I had no idea that I had 86
urethral sphincter that's some of the
most dubious advice we've never offered
you do you do it there are some so I
think I think I haven't looked this up
that there are some there are some that
are controlled by your sympathetic
nervous system you're like like some
like the this just like your body doing
body things and there are some that are
controlled by your mind and when those
when your body says it's time to pee
you only have one like mind controllable
do not pee system thing that actually
you control and if your body lets go of
all of them it can be very difficult to
keep that one any I think it even even
relaxed intentionally relax the last one
without your permission and that is as
much as I know but I mean that seems
very dubious I just gotta tell you the
truth I think
you know your body is just like oh it's
the time we're here it's time to do this
go go go which time but yeah I do
I yeah this is absolutely a thing all of
us agree yeah it's definitely a thing
let's move on to another question though
Hank this question is a hugely important
and difficult and complicated it comes
from Anthony who writes Dear John and
Hank should I delete the sent from my
iphone in emails I send from my iPhone
what you know how at the bottom of an
email from your iPhone it says sent from
my iphone yeah should you have that
signature in an email sent from your
mobile device or should you have no
mobile device signifier at all here's
what you should do so I have some
friends who do a thing which is they
will leave a message like excuse any
typos I wrote this on my phone I don't
like sent from my iphone because it
seems a little bit like I'm so special I
have an iPhone yeah it's like I don't
want a brand integration in my email
right agreed
I should be getting paid for that right
I don't have anything though I just I
just cut it off completely you know what
I have Jon that way I don't have to
write that way I don't have to write my
name at the end of the email a 100% at
the time it just says John so al here's
an idea
how about I put in my email signature
sent from my iphone that way you think
I'm super busy and like so important
that I wrote this like five page email
I mean iPhone that's a good idea but
Anthony if I could make one
recommendation it would be to change
your iPhone email signature to just say
John because I think I think that's the
statement you want to make is that that
this was sent from John Hank I have
another question okay this one comes
from Grace who writes Dear John and Hank
I'm a high school senior and it is now
the time of year when everyone is asking
for signatures in their yearbooks to
remember you by this question might be a
little bit dated but don't worry we're
still gonna answer it however I don't
know half of these people currently I'm
drawing random internet memes in the
yearbooks of people I don't know to
avoid writing the cliche responses like
never change or have a great summer what
do you write in the yearbooks of people
you hardly know I think writing never
by the way is a huge mistake yeah
because you should definitely please
change yeah if I could say one thing to
my 16 year old self it would be change
just one word to change yeah maybe
that's what you should write Grace in
big capital letters be different from
the way you were I didn't like it that
much
I didn't know you but I bet you need to
change yeah
grow up no just grow not girl just grow
I why are you writing in the strangers
books anyway Hank do you not remember
high school this was a huge part of high
school experience that you have to sign
yearbooks for people with whom you are
not terribly well acquainted yeah I'm
not terribly well acquainted I this is
something we actually have experience in
because on a pretty regular basis we
sign items for people whom we don't know
well yeah and so we have a strategy for
doing this and I think it's actually
quite a good strategy I don't know your
strategy is mine is that I write best
wishes
exclamation point and I sign my name I
have a couple yeah so it helps if you
can come up with something cute that you
can draw quickly write like a Hank or
like a Hank or fish but it's good to
have that in general then you can draw
something and then that's nice you made
them a thing
and then sometimes alright just keep
swimming because it's a fish mm-hmm next
to the fish that's good or I'll write
dftba dftb a is a winner for me because
it's five characters long so you can get
it done pretty quickly and don't forget
to be awesome is reasonably good advice
- more or less everyone yeah yep so
grace we're gonna say either ear draw
fish and say just keep swimming
well that's mine don't do that that's
also good advice you to be fair get a
get a draw giraffe and say reach for the
highest Apple don't think giraffes eat
apples exceptionally displace yeah hey
fish don't swim this is the worst
episode of dear Hank and John ever this
is the word of God
fish don't swim this is the one that
we've made entirely for ourselves in
zero percent for our listeners we're
clearly like punch drunk on VidCon
anxiety and we need to move on to
another question but grace
congratulations on finishing another
year of school good job if our if it
sounds like we're getting a lot of text
messages it's because we are alright
this one's from iris who asks dear Hank
and John I have a lot of red curly hair
and people always tell me how beautiful
it is which is flattering however total
strangers also think seem to think it's
okay to touch my hair without asking
permission
I find this uncomfortable and it makes
me anxious but I never know what to say
so my question is what's the polite way
to sell to tell someone that you don't
want them to touch you I have a version
of this I don't have beautiful curly red
hair but I have a version of this which
is that people often ask to touch my
puffs right when I meet them because he
got got a puffy hair even when I was at
a bar last night someone just touched it
without asking or anything and it also
makes me anxious I think any time a
stranger is touching you without your
permission it's a little bit of an
imposition yeah I don't I don't know if
it can't be done with a facial
expression maybe not to everybody but to
some people I think there are certain
facial expressions that will tell them
that in fact the thing you have done is
incorrect yeah and then maybe but they
won't do it in the future but it doesn't
help you for like you've maybe taught
them an important lesson but you haven't
you haven't solved your problem which is
that you don't like your red hair being
touched by strangers who haven't asked
for permission so first off let's just
establish as a rule the same way we have
the armrest wrangle that dear Hank and
John listeners or Dear John and Hank
listeners I prefer to think of them do
not touch strangers without asking for
permission let's just not do it okay
let's just I mean unless like you're you
know you're in a subway and you jostle
against there if you're in a mosh pit at
a conference you are on a concert that's
what I meant yeah veerudu möchte if you
go to a really great dentistry
conference and they have one of those
great dentist mosh pits so those are the
best those are the
those people know how to party oh man
they got the laughing gas well yeah and
also they can just fix their teeth if
they get knocked out that's true so you
don't have to worry yeah yeah this is
the worst episode it's real bad I don't
we shout this mosh pit I know what we're
gonna call it yeah the word episode no I
thought we're gonna call the worst
episode ever oh that's better
that's better that's good you know
you're a theory clever you're a clever
chap in summary unless you're a mosh pit
don't touch strangers especially if they
have curly red hair because they've
probably been treated as like weird
objects of fetishization and
objectification for their entire lives
and it's unpleasant for them okay sorry
that happened to you Rebecca I've got
another question John I can't wait it's
from Kylie who asks dear Hank and John I
know that dust is particles of air dirt
yep good clean my house pretty often and
yet it always gets all over my things
yeah what is dust anyways and how can I
keep potentially harmful substance and
how can I keep this potentially harmful
substance from collecting so often and
invading my nostrils and a dubious
advice is greatly appreciated first off
my understanding is that dust is made
out of like human leftovers a great deal
of it is indeed little bits of skin oh
god I think I recently recap it's other
stuff is that makes you feel any better
not really
I recently recount along my home library
which was an extraordinarily fulfilling
experience as I'm sure you can imagine
and in the process I dusted each of each
of my books individually and then dusted
all the shelves and everything and it is
astonishing how much dust collects on
items yes it's almost like we shouldn't
have items almost like we shouldn't have
horizontal surfaces in our homes time
did not have any horizontal surfaces to
get to live in an elevator shaft well
you need a floor
yeah yeah yeah it's true it's a good
point here doesn't live in a bottomless
pit
I'm not horizontal surfaces I'm just
falling I'm not an architect but I mean
they have it doesn't here's your new
home good news bad news good news not a
does problem bad news it is an eternally
falling pit you will eventually I think
get used to it but cell phone service is
gonna be a problem how long could you
fall if there were a theoretical hole
through the entire earth mm-hmm how long
could you fall you would what I mean I
know I know you would die because you
would get very warm well if you say
would it you would in an air-conditioned
pool fall forever in a way because you
would fall yeah and then you would reach
the other side and you would fall back
and sort of yoyo back and forth so it is
I mean if then eventually you would
settle in the middle of a gravitational
center of the earth yeah and then you
would just sit there and so you would
have and and no dust there would be dust
it would just like they have dust on the
space station and they have to control
for it but it doesn't settle the same
way it like sir just gets into
everything oh great alright so problem
not solved cutting a hole through the
earth is not going to work as a solution
to our because the problem okay I yeah I
having a smaller home space does help
because it's easier to keep clean and
and also I would what I will say about
dusting is that a great deal of dusting
is just putting the dust back into the
air whether it will once again fall
correct so doing things that actually
absorb the dust and then washing that
thing is much better than just like
fluffing the dust off so that it can
once again land upon all of your things
that's my home maintenance tip from Hank
green home maintenance expert I mean
that's just extraordinarily do business
advice you
hey we're recording dear Hank and John
hey mid-con it's hey John yeah you snap
chatting yes all right let's move on to
a slightly more serious question
although dust is a very serious problem
I don't want to minimize it this
question comes from Lauren who asks dear
John and Hank every once in a while I
have this feeling creep inexplicably up
on me and the only way I can describe it
is homesickness it's a bit of a tight
feeling in the chest and stomach that's
part nostalgia and part anxiety
the thing is I'm 36 and I'm actually not
homesick nor would going to my own home
or my parents home make the feeling go
away do you ever have this sort of
feeling and if so what the heck I do
have this feeling and reading this
question felt like someone was seeing
very specifically inside of me which is
not a feeling I have that often that
like somebody was feeling something that
feels to me quite private and so I was
fascinated by the question do you have
this feeling think is it is it a kind of
nostalgia that is it it is that what
we're talking about it's not quite
nostalgia I actually usually describe it
as as dread or longing or like a place
between dread and longing but it is a
very specific feeling in my in my chest
and stomach where I feel a distance from
something that I want to feel close to
but I don't quite know what the thing is
it's a very I used to when I was a kid I
had it when I was a kid too and when I
was a kid I would call it the night
feeling because I had it mostly at night
which was when I sort of like my
anxieties would would be allowed to like
run wild you don't have this feeling
don't think so I think that's good news
for you
although it's not I have to say it's not
a wholly bad feeling the other time I
get it maybe this will help you is when
I'm driving alone on a highway at night
and I feel a sort of mix of poignancy
and
yearning but I don't quite know for what
is this it all helpful nope Hank doesn't
have feelings like the rest of us have
feelings I yeah alright don't have aa
dick I'm sorry
Lauren Lauren Hank obviously not
qualified to answer this question but
then again that doesn't usually stop him
oh I will say what we have a t6 urethral
sphincter I will say you are not alone
in this feeling I know you're not alone
because I also have it and I think maybe
it's part of being a person that you
yearn for something that you don't quite
know what it is and I think just being
okay with that makes the feeling less
scary at least for me so that is my
dubious advice and now we will move on
to a question that Hank feels that he
can't answer because it's not about
feelings all right this one's from
Gerardo who asks dear Hank and John I
work as a lifeguard every summer and
over the course of this past year I
gained some weight which had the
unexpected consequence that there is a
spot on my back I cannot reach to apply
sunscreen I don't want to ask the other
guards because it's embarrassing but I
would also not like to get but I would
also like to not get skin cancer on that
one spot in my back any dubious advice
as to how to cover your entire back with
sunscreen as a larger slash Lex less
less less flexible person yes
you got you got this one oh yeah well
this is a problem that I have I also
have a spot in my back that I can't
reach and I have the spray on sunscreen
yeah which i think is a fantastic it's
under appreciated as a product and B
it's extremely effective you can spray
it like at least 10 inches away from the
spot so if you can get within 10 inches
of the spot you can get there with the
spray on sunscreen so that that's what I
would say I just put some sunscreen on
the wall and then I just rub up against
it
now I do like the spare on the sunscreen
I have I have a problem with it what is
it that they put something in it that
makes it taste bad hmm and I'm not
saying I'm spraying it in my mouth I was
gonna say it seems like a pretty easy
problem to avoid the thing it also
doesn't recommend that you eat sunscreen
problem is it tastes
it smells like delicious coconut but it
tastes awful let me ask you this Hank
how does a hum how does regular
sunscreen taste is it delicious
do you like okay I think that they put
some kind of bitter and in it so that
people don't Huff it
they put really rias I think that they
put something in it makes it and like I
am like every time I use it like there's
this very strong bitter taste in my
mouth if I get if I like breathe at all
while you're happening well it's mean
again I don't want to underscore this
Hank but you shouldn't Huff the
sunscreen that's the problem okay if
they didn't mind in the future but yeah
this brown stuff you don't have to
because it's a little more expensive you
don't use it on your whole body but you
can use it on that one spot just use it
on that one spot and then use the cheap
sunscreen for the rest of your body that
is exactly what I do by the way because
I don't I think the spray on sunscreen
is a bit of a scam because it feels like
it's a lot of sunscreen but it's really
not yeah it's just like a highly
pressurized can yep alright I'm glad
that we I'm glad that we're on the same
page about sunscreen even if we aren't
on the same page about the iourney
feeling that one sometimes gets unless
one is Hank alright we've got another
question from Lauren who asks dear Hank
and John help do you know how to keep my
headphone cord from getting tangled no
no no no no no and I hate I mean I try
my best and I have a system and I like
wrap it up around my hand and then I
wrap it around wrap and I put it in my
pocket and then I take it out of my
pocket and it's made of knots so Hank
this is actually a subject of like like
a pretty intensely studied subject in
mathematics yeah because it's a weird
pattern and there is this thing called
spontaneous nada
of an agitated string that like over
time an agitated headphone cord or other
string will tie itself into like
incredibly complicated knots and the
short answer is that there is some
awareness that this happens but we don't
really know why at least like the math
like hi my understanding and I mean I am
definitely not a mathematician is that
there this is still like a fertile
ground of research rather than a settled
question right I understand the
specifics of it is actually important
for biology because understanding how
DNA which is a very long string rapes
itself organized and when it does not
what happens because it does happen and
that actually creates disease but the
the sort of like broad top level reason
why headphones get tangled is because
there are more ways infinitely more ways
for a string to be knotted than to be
not knotted there is only one way for a
string to not have knots in it mmm it
has one state there are an infinite
number of ways for it to be knotted
literally infinite yes well no not if
there's not a fifth the if it if it was
a if it was a line and did not have like
oh it was an infinitely long line there
would be infinite number or even if it
didn't have thickness oh just like it's
sort of imaginary string that did not
have a width okay
all right now my mind is pretty blown so
that's a good feeling that's always nice
by the way Hanks wearing turkey leg
socks today it's controversial choice
well they are turkey legs with legs
they're walking around um I got them as
gift they're great they are I love them
speaking of gifts Hank I just want to do
one quick follow-up Amy wrote back Dear
John and Hank thank you for answering my
question concerning the inherently
unsexy pizza John t-shirt you remember
Amy Hanks she was the one who was having
trouble right kissing her boyfriend
because he was having to stare at my
face in the pizza John shirt I've taken
your advice and purchased the shirt from
FTB a.com that doesn't have John's face
on it as you can see from the attached
photo which we'll post at the patreon
Matthew and I are thrilled Pizza John
meanwhile has not been abandoned but he
has been relegated to the cuddling
sector thanks again
Amy PS John you made a mistake when
reading the original question at the
time I was asking Matthew and I had been
dating for two months not two years but
here's to two years and Beyond thanks to
your dubious advice and then there's a
lovely picture of Amy and Matthew and
Amy's new giraffe love t-shirt from
dftba.com which I designed you do I will
wear that certain people will say I love
your shirt and then I will have to say
because it's true I did this technically
you don't have to say that but it
doesn't mind me that today's podcast is
brought to you by Hanks ego oh no thanks
ego covering high quality podcasting
since 2015 I have no idea what we talked
about I've not talked a lot about Leon
muffs
this podcast is not brought to you by
Leon month that's a live on sir that
would be a conflict of interest
twitter.com slash Leon must number for
Earth Witter I don't consider that are
literally the best Twitter on earth no
this podcast is also brought to you if I
spray on sunscreen it tastes bad
terrible advertisement for spray on
sunscreen spray on sunscreen spray on
sunscreen it tastes bad hard to huff
don't Huff it and today's podcast is
also brought to you by the longing
homesickness deep in your chest the
longing homesickness deep in your chest
a feeling that Hank has never had and
finally this podcast is brought to you
by all 86 of your urethral sphincter
loosening up one by one as you get
closer to your apartment all right Hank
we've got time for one last question I'm
wondering if we can try to steer this
episode of the podcast back towards
something you know vaguely redeemable so
this question don't sweat this question
comes from Jordan who writes Dear John
and Hank I am sitting in my car in the
parking lot of my workplace and I can't
motivate myself to walk inside right now
I hate my job and the thought of doing
it today has me in tears dubious advice
so look I've had this feeling a few
times in my life I've had an incredibly
lucky and and privileged professional
life but I have had this feeling in my
in my younger years and the first thing
I would say is that this is an
opportunity to begin to try to find a
new job it may be that you cannot find a
new job today it may be that it's not
practical or possible for you to leave
this job that you hate today but this is
probably this is dubious advice but I
think this is probably a message from
yourself that it is time to try to start
finding some other kind of work yeah I
mean yes and and hopefully that will
give you some hope as you go into doing
the thing that you have to do in order
to make it work because I assume that
this is part of you making it work that
having that like knowledge that you were
working toward something more than the
current state yeah I think there were
two things that were helpful to me when
I felt that way one was I am doing this
job for a specific that I hate for a
specific reason which is to pay my bills
which is to take care of myself and
people I care about which is to meet my
obligations and while it is difficult
and unfun and it is not forever it is
for right now today the thing that I can
do to meet those obligations
to myself and to the people I love and
the second thing was to find something
that I was passionate about that I cared
about that I could get better at by
doing in the time when I wasn't working
which for me was writing the book that
became Looking for Alaska and and that
really helped in the time when I had
this feeling most profoundly was when I
was working as a chaplain when I really
I was really bad at that job and it's a
horrible job to be bad at and it's
impossible not to dread going to work
unless you are a saint when you know
that you know kids might die and that
you're not going to be very good at
helping people in that situation I think
it's I think it's possible to enjoy that
work when you know that you can be
helpful and useful but I knew that I
wasn't that good at it and it really
helped me to say well this is what I'm
doing right now because I made a
commitment to do it but I am also going
to go home tonight and I am going to do
this thing that I love which is writing
and working during the day is what
facilitates me being able to do this job
that I or do this work that I love at
night right and even if you can just do
like work on something that you are
progressing at mm-hmm just an hour a day
is huge because I think that's what we
all want is to be getting better at
being people and sometimes our work that
we get paid for does not allow us to do
that
and and that can be very frustrating and
so much so that it's hard to have the
energy or the willpower to do anything
yeah anything active when you're when
you're not at work but finding that
thing and and getting through the sort
of initial stages of definitely being
bad at it right that's usually how it
starts out unless you're very lucky so
being very bad at I'm working until you
are manageably good and it becomes fun
and you understand and and can see your
own progression which has been you know
really great for me creatively just to
play guitar badly right it's just such a
nice thing to be able to do or not even
play guitar like whether it's you know
running or whatever it is you know there
I don't think it has to be something
creative necessarily I think lots of
people find fulfilment in sports or in
all kinds of different human activities
but that sense of being able to get
better at something that sense of being
able to to have something in your life
that that isn't work that's important to
you can make work more manageable but I
also don't want to minimize this this
sucks and I know there are lots of
people who feel this way every morning
when they go to work and it sucks and I
think part of what maybe makes it
survivable is acknowledging that it does
suck yeah and also acknowledging that
like if you want to trade this bad job
for another bad job your other bad job
might not be as bad because it's in my
experience it's usually the people
you're working with more than the job
itself and if you can find a place even
if it's a crappy job if there's good
people there it makes it all more
manageable the only exception to that is
when you have to do a lot of cold
calling then it doesn't matter if you
work yeah it's always terrible I'm sure
there's lots of exceptions to that
that's true the only exception in my
person is when there's cold calling
involved but yeah I'm sure there's lots
of jobs that where it isn't about the
people you work with but but having
better coworkers definitely makes a huge
difference like I worked at a few
restaurants
and whether the job was fun or or okay
or absolutely horrible depended entirely
on whether I was able to get along with
my coworkers
yeah all right Hank it's time to move on
to the all-important news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon do you want me to start or
would you like to start
I always start I think the news from AFC
Wimbledon is that this week AFC
Wimbledon's League one third tier
schedule was announced we are playing
the likes of Swindon Town Oxford United
Gillingham mmm sounds delicious your
favorite ham and of course Port Vale
you know Bristol Rovers some big clubs
but that the marquee matchup the
franchise from Milton Keynes is also
down in League One AFC Wimbledon have
worked their way up from the ninth tier
to the third tier the hard-working
franchise in Milton Keynes has worked
their way in the same period all the way
from the third tier of English football
to the third tier of English football
and those games will be on March 14th is
when the franchise will come to visit
AFC Wimbledon and on December 10th AFC
Wimbledon we're playing on will be
playing in Milton Keynes big games for
me include the game against Swindon Town
the home game against Swindon Town on
October 15th a longtime Swindon Town fan
as well and I'm excited to go to a game
I know I'm going to at least one game
this season October 1st home to
Gillingham pretty excited about that
fired up very very excited for AFC
Wimbledon's lead 1 schedule will post
the whole schedule on the patreon so you
can enjoy it and if you want to go to
one of the games yeah you should go to
more than one of the games hang any of
the games so Hank yeah Leon must for
Earth has a question for you how God are
we closer you're not gonna just let me
or farther away to getting to Mars this
week well physically we're farther away
from Mars this week
that's moving away from us now another
solid week gotta come come back around
again in a couple of years in earth ness
but yes practically we're a little bit
closer because nASA has signed an
agreement with the United Arab Emirates
sharing information and technology in
the hopes of collaborating on a bunch of
stuff but the prime objective according
to the announcement is the exploration
of Mars by humans or by robots by humans
that's disappointing but this is NASA's
plan so its goal is to get to Mars by
2030 perfect
I've always loved NASA and they they
want to and that that plan has been
criticized for its ambitiousness yeah
I'm all for getting to Mars in 2030 I
think that'd be great
that way I could that way we could get
humans to Mars and have a podcast called
Dear John and Hank so so as part of that
which could cost upwards of trillion
dollars they are they're partnering with
a number of different countries and the
United Arab Emirates is a wealthy oil
State and they they are working on some
of their own Mars missions they have a
plan to send an unmanned probe to Mars
by 2021 and and and the NASA is signing
similar cooperative agreements with or
has signed with China Russia and the UK
hmm and knowing that I you know I if
we're gonna do this it's gonna cost a
lot of money and it's not just gonna be
something that one country is gonna do
by itself so NASA is working behind the
scenes to to oh here's here's what
Charlie Bolden says the director of NASA
together we can bring humanity to the
face of Mars and reach new heights for
the benefit of all humankind in 2020 and
we will in 2028 really should have
pushed it to 2030 Hank we got an
interesting question from Bobby who
wrote in to say I was listening to the
episode where Hank was talking about the
Mars mission that they're planning where
there's 40 people and they're going to
narrow it down to 26 people and then
send them to Mars four at a time and I
couldn't help but notice that 26 is not
divisible by
for any ideas on how that'll work I
think yeah I think that one of the
missions will have two people I think
that they're just assuming that some
people will die they're just building it
in alright okay yeah no III think that I
think maybe the first mission is planned
to be just to but I'm not sure Oh that'd
be great I have always wanted to go to
Mars with just one other person and then
die there I mean the thing is maybe you
really like them and get along real well
I mean I play a lot of FIFA
can you play FIFA on Mars of course
did they have Wi-Fi no but you can play
two player on the same box oh you're
gonna have Wi-Fi but they're not gonna
you can't play like like you could not
play fifa with someone on earth if you
were on Mars you couldn't no I mean yeah
the lag would be a little pretty yes you
can play chess mate so what you're
saying is they will have Wi-Fi on Mars
but I won't be able to Skype do you know
that the internet used to be a capital I
according to the AP style guide oh you
recently pushed it to lowercase I mean
this is huge news for me Hank because I
have always styled Internet with a
capital I because I believe in the AP
style guide in all of my books it's
capital I yeah and even sometimes my
copy editors would be like this is
technically a capital line but nobody
really uses the capital I and I would be
like we use the capital line because we
believe the AP style guide so it was a
little bit of a betrayal I thought it
would be a huge relief it is it's both a
relief and a betrayal because I stood up
for the capital I internet for so long
that now I agree with them that it
should be a lowercase I thing but it's
made now my books look dated yeah as
opposed to before when they were just
full of a bunch of references to bands
like The Flaming Lips Flaming Lips are
still relevant John I've always thought
that the Internet should be a lower case
because there can be more than one of
them and if there is if we do go to Mars
there will be a Mars Internet and an
earth Internet there will be - I bet the
Martian Internet isn't gonna be as good
no definitely not
yes I mean yet one more reason why try
to build an Internet from scratch asks
Leon Maas
you tweet it when we've got an Internet
working right here yeah I've got to go
actually because I I did just discover a
jiff that I want to tweet as Leon Maas
all right well what did we learn today
John well we learned that Leon must for
earth number four is your number one
news source for not getting to Mars
before 2028 just tell me what I just
tell me what I'm kicking the dead horse
I know it's not yet I know that horse is
alive but he also you tell me when I
jumped the shark on the Leon must stuff
all right we also learned yeah that John
mmm-hmm on the set of Paper Towns yep
peed on something I don't know what but
something he was not supposed to pee off
we learned that a Hank
Huff's spray on sunscreen not true
purpose well I mean that's all I'm
saying is that I have no idea how to
spray on sunscreen tastes and we also I
think I just have an exceptionally
strong sense of taste I have a very a
very developed palate
oh my god aren't you special and finally
we learned that John would like a house
with no bottom forever falling pit that
disallows the existence of any dust I
just want to live in a vacuum is that so
wrong
yeah it saves you from all of the
potential bugs that might be in your
home if your home is a vacuum they just
die immediately the other big advantage
is that you also die yeah so that's a
bummer
yeah okay let's uh let's wrap up the fun
all right thank you for listening to
this podcast John thank you for coming
to Anaheim to record with me it's a
pleasure to have you here I mean it's
not like you're hosting me we both run
VidCon it's just I don't work on it
and thank you very one for listening to
this podcast where you can you can find
this podcast now officially on the
Google Play podcasts thingy well that's
exciting yeah also we want to thank all
of our patreon subscribers at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John and
we want to thank Nicholas Jenkins who
edits the podcast Claudia Morales is our
intern rosianna halse rojas helps us
with questions our theme music is by
gunnarolla thank you again for listening
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome and if you have any
questions you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com I forgot that part
this really is the worst episode ever
so bad